smart guns unique to a single user could
soon become available in the united
states promoters hope to avoid tragedies
with what they say is gun control but
the implications don't chime with the
wishes of the powerful pro-gun lobbies
so could this lead to the government
having the power to regulate the gun
market this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
peter dobby over the past 20 years the
idea of smart guns which can be fired
only by verified users has been
developed and debated around the world
but there haven't been reliable results
until now some american gun makers have
started testing personalized smart guns
they say they could be soon available
for consumers in the united states
supporters say the guns could reduce
suicides render lost or stolen guns
useless and protect security personnel
but attempts to develop smart guns in
the past have failed one made by a
german company was easily hacked and in
the u.s those who want the right to bear
arms opposed the new technology some
critics said smart guns were too risky
for people trying to protect their home
during a crisis the national shooting
sports foundation in the u.s says it
doesn't oppose smart guns as long as the
government doesn't enforce their sale
in most developed countries government
control of guns is strict and widely
accepted but in the united states it is
of course a controversial political
issue gun control is a broad term mainly
used to refer to restrictions on what
kind of weapons can be sold who can
possess or sell them and where and how
they can be stored or carried proponents
of gun control in the u.s say that
limiting access to arms would save lives
and reduce crime opponents argue the
opposite saying it would prevent
law-abiding citizens from defending
themselves against armed criminals
the u.s has by far the highest rates of
homicides by firearms among the
developed countries in a small arms
survey back in 2018 a swiss-based
research project found that there were
120.5 firearms in the u.s for every 100
residents in 2019 there were 14 400 gun
related homicides killings involving a
gun accounted for nearly three-quarters
of all homicides in the u.s in that year
figures from the centers for disease
control and prevention show there were
more than 38
300 deaths from guns in 2019 of which
more than 23 900 were suicides and
attacks have become deadlier than
anywhere else in las vegas in 2017 a man
fired more than 1 000 bullets from his
hotel window on a crowd at a music
festival he killed 60 people in the
worst mass shooting in recent u.s
history
okay let's get going let's bring in our
guests in keene new hampshire we have
richard feldman the former regional
political director national rifle
association and author of ricochet
confessions of a gun lobbyist in oakland
we have pastor mike mcbride director of
live free campaign and the co-founder of
the national black brown gun violence
prevention consortium in arlington we
have chuck nesbi he's a firearms
instructor and formerly a naval officer
gentlemen welcome to the program richard
feldman in new hampshire coming to you
first personalized guns
what are the what are the good points
and what are the bad points
well i the personalized gun
being something that is only operational
by the authorized user uh one can see
instances where that would be a very
good thing they were originally
developed over 20 years ago primarily
for law enforcement who from time to
time in a scuffle will have their gun
taken from them by the perpetrator and
it's of course in the interest of law
enforcement for the gun not to operate
if it's in the hands of the bad guy
rather than the good guy
so
i think we're we can all see where it
would be
valuable in certain circumstances the
problems and thus the downside is you
can't envision all the circumstances and
depending on the technology it affects
the outcome
there was somewhere it operated off of
fingerprints well if you're in a fight
and you get your hands in the dirt the
gun wouldn't operate because you can't
read your fingerprints if it works off a
battery what if the battery goes dead in
the middle of your scuffle and your gun
doesn't operate
so at the end of the day it's probably
the market that's going to determine is
it a valuable tool is it worth the tool
there are always
costs benefits and detriments to
everything and
our system usually works things out on a
monetary basis is it going to be worth
the price and how does the ba how do the
equities balance in the use of the gun
chuck masby in arlington uh so the
technology is not infallible
if we are getting to the point where the
technology is a-okay absolutely
trustworthy will gun owners be prepared
in your mind to stump up the extra cash
because these weapons are more expensive
than that the traditional
still quite simple 100 years after it
went into common usage still quite
simple technology that represents a
basic handgun
well first i agree with everything that
your previous speaker just said
second
the technology is still a long way from
being
liable
the guns are going to be very expensive
there it's an old technology about 40
years old
the military has not decided to buy the
guns because of reliability and expense
the law enforcement community
the same reason reasons has rejected the
gun and why would the civilian market
buy a gun that's extremely expensive and
uh questionable reliability if the
domestic police won't use it why should
the uh civilian community use it
okay pastor mike mcbride in oakland 90
of teenage suicides in america
the people that kill themselves use a
gun it's a gun that they've got
from a relative
uh
it's very easy in america with 300
million guns in circulation to go into
grandpa's arsenal and get your weapon of
choice and end your own life
would they be a good thing
if we just talk about
suicide if we were having a conversation
now about suicide not about gun control
would we be saying this is a great idea
uh absolutely i do believe we should
shift the conversation uh beyond just
conversation around the market or
reliability but we should see smart guns
or personalized firearms as a solution
to the kinds of
accidental shootings the kinds of uh
shootings involving suicides uh it's
about ensuring that we have a viable
alternative
for families and individuals who would
like to have a firearm legally but also
ensure that that firearm does not fall
into the hands of curious children or uh
underage minors who often are involved
in accidental shootings suicides or even
interpersonal conflicts and so part of
our conversation must uh expand to i
believe a public health uh conversation
not just one that depends on the what
the military does or what law
enforcement personnel uh may do uh the
vast majority of
gun owners in this country are civilians
that need to have public health viable
solutions that provide both security and
safety at the same time richard feldman
why are smart guns not as commercialized
as perhaps one would assume at this
point in the life of people using
handguns they're not as commercialized
as one would assume they might be it's
kind of counterintuitive so where's the
dynamic going to come from is it the gun
lobby the gun manufacturers
big business sponsors or government
well i think it's going to be the
marketplace and that
encapsulates all of those you mentioned
but you know i i agree with what the
pastor just said
you know it's in our we have a
responsibility to do a much better job
keeping guns out of the hands
of people who every one of us on this
call and every gun owner i know believes
ought not have guns but why would we
want to use
the most
technologically advanced difficult
expensive system i haven't we can do it
right now they're called gun safes
i'm the guy that with
president clinton back in 1997
when i represented the firearms industry
announced we were going to ship all guns
with child safety locks
when you have a gun in the home
why don't we start
having people
get safes safes aren't very expensive
small safes that can hold a couple of
guns we're talking about not five
hundred a thousand dollars and up we're
talking around a hundred dollars if
people the grandpa who's got his guns if
he left his guns in a safe his grandkids
aren't going to be able to access those
guns it's a simple solution that we can
do now for a lot less cost
chuck lesbian arlington coming back to
you
has richard feldman kind of nailed or
pigeonholed the debate there i.e it's
not a binary decision despite the fact
that candidate
joe biden was in favor of smart guns
when he was on the campaign trail and
barack obama was in favor of smart guns
it's not as simple as saying it's smart
guns or traditional guns it's got to be
part of a portfolio of reducing the
death toll and the inappropriate use of
handguns
yes let me uh say that i totally agree
with mr feldman
uh
the democrat administrations of uh bill
clinton and uh barack obama
both have studies conducted by the cdc
from a health perspective on
firearm safety
i want to correct once one thing
the number of suicides by firearm is
very very low compared to the
all the methodologies that are used for
suicide
as an instructor one of the things we
cover very detailed
is the security of guns the
responsibility with them
many states have instituted laws that if
guns are not secured properly and they
are misused the owner of that gun is
held criminally
so with good training
we can
emphasize uh the security of firearms
the responsibility that goes with it
and minimize
the illegal use of their arms pastor
mike mcbride in oakland i guess that's a
fair point sir isn't it that suicide is
suicide and if somebody wants to take
their own life they will do it they may
do it
they may take a longer time to do it
they may do it in a slightly more messy
way a less surgical way if you will but
if somebody wants to top themselves they
don't necessarily have to use a gun to
do it but
do you get the sense where you are
that
the nra is resisting this despite what
the the industry is saying because the
industry is now saying look we're
getting a better reception from the gun
lobby
well i think it's important to just say
uh while many can use various uh methods
to attempt suicides the use of guns are
the most um successful uh
weapons or tools used when suicides do
occur meaning that uh you may be able to
recover from a pill overdose or using a
razor blades or other forms but once you
pull a trigger it's very hard to come
back from that and this is i think the
point we can't allow the perfect to be
the enemy of the good uh the data says
that 37 of deaths could be prevented
with these kind of personalized firearms
which means to say that we ought to be
thinking about mitigation efforts uh
ways to ensure that we are reducing the
harm not uh figuring out a hundred
percent uh fail-safe proof method uh a
holistic response that includes i agree
uh safety locks and and and other forms
of ways to secure weapons ought not be
seen as oppositional to personal
firearms because all collectively
together we could indeed uh increase the
number
or the percentage of of uh preventable
debts and that i think is the point uh
in our communities it is not just about
suicides in the black community in urban
communities not just about suicides but
it's also about accidental shootings
it's also about stolen firearms it's
also about the ways in which guns make
it into the underground market and then
come into the hands of our community
members who are often uh seduced into um
using weapons to resolve personal
conflict so the the conversation must be
expanded i think continuously beyond
just a a a a 100 percent fail-safe proof
conversation to a public health uh a
mitigation conversation that i think
will allow many if not all of our
solutions to work together
to achieve the the shared
outcomes and that is more safe richard
feldman is there a sense in which
they're looking forward smart guns or
the enforced deployment of smart guns
might be good in as much as
the manufacturing and the use and the
availability of particularly handguns is
generally a function of boom or bust
within the contractual financial side of
the industry i.e looking at it globally
it depends where the united states is
fighting and killing people and then the
contracts when the united states stops
doing that kind of thing or stops
peacekeeping the contracts are then
wrapped up with the gun makers and then
there's a surplus of guns on the market
in the u.s
now that that may have been true
you know around world war ii and
before but
civilians buy
20 30 40 50 times more guns in the
united states than the military
purchases and the guns the military's
primarily interested in aren't available
on the commercial market for civilians
they're two separate and distinct
markets
so that that's not true and again you
know i i really agree with the pastor
there there's no one solution and when
he says you know the the perfect uh
shouldn't be uh or rather the practical
shouldn't be the enemy of the perfect uh
well you know in a perfect world the
smart gun would be the perfect solution
but it's got problems it will always
have problems
and frankly those gangs could still
steal
the um
personalized guns and figure out how to
um uh get rid of the
uh
the personalization if a gun is in a
safe it can't be stolen so easily
without stealing the whole safe or
breaking the safe um i mean sometimes we
look for the most incredible solutions
when a simple solution
will suffice
quite well at a much lower cost without
all the inconvenience
and and the debate
chuckling sometimes just like that fight
about it pardon me for interrupting you
chuck now to be coming back to you would
incremental legislation perhaps
represent a middle path
moving forwards because then people who
like their guns and the gun lobby the
very powerful
political gun lobby wouldn't feel that
they were being presented with this
black or white choice of we're going to
take away your traditional guns and you
must must use the smart guns
no that wouldn't work uh one there's a
constitutional amendment to our
constitution called the second amendment
that
that protects the rights of the citizens
to own firearms second
uh
i agree with the holistic approach
we think that if you make the penalties
more difficult
that would cut down a lot of the
misuse for example
if you illegally use a firearm and
you're convicted of such in a court of
law
mandatory sentencing say
automatic 20 years uh
i think that's something the gun lobby
would support
and it's awful something that would
cut down on the illegal use of guns
because the bad guys would say the cost
is too high pastor mike mcbride in
oakland
is it significant that johns hopkins is
saying 60 percent on his website today
they're saying this 60 of first-time gun
buyers would buy smart technology over
ordinary technology if it
was readily available or is it just that
they don't know what they're buying so
they just want to go for the latest
glitziest top of the line handgun with
all the technology built in i definitely
think it is significant because we have
begin begun to win the argument
nationally
in the gun violence prevention space
over and against the gun lobby and gun
manufacturers who seem to love to raise
straw man arguments about why these
things won't work but are perfectly okay
with the carnage and the blood spilling
that is happening all across the country
with the lucy goosey
over and available um use and of
firearms i do believe that uh firearm
consumers are wanting to do their part
to ensure that we can
literally reduce preventable deaths uh
on even in this conversation the idea
that one-third of preventable deaths
could be impacted uh by these
introduction of firearms um smart
firearms it's as if that is a small
insignificant number we must again allow
of those with very sensible and uh
committed um arguments around protecting
and saving and and and maintaining
security around guns we must allow those
arguments to carry the day and perhaps
the industry the market the
manufacturing of these these kinds of
smart firearms will grow because the
demand will grow and therein we will
have more options we will have more
better technology
in this whole uh sector richard feldman
just to nail down if i can for the next
minute or so what your stance seems to
be the pastor there is saying you can
reduce deaths by one third the lowest
state percentage that i found today says
you can reduce
death by gun by 25
doesn't that therefore mean
that everyone should embrace the
technology and push for the technology
to be readily available once it is a
hundred percent guaranteed as this
functions it works it does what it says
on the tin
you know what you're leaving out of the
equation is the people that don't own
guns think this new technology is a
great idea
the people who own guns and want to own
guns don't like the technology for the
most part and it's true the market will
decide so the people that buy guns
aren't interested and don't want it the
people that don't own guns think that
the other people who do own them ought
to have it therein lies the conundrum
because it is the market ultimately that
will decide and the market is of gun
owners not of anti-gun non-gun owners
and chuck lesby in arlington going back
to this idea of pro and anti-gun lobbies
do we have to does the united states
have to disassemble this kind of a
political metric where you've got this
simplistic assumption republicans like
their guns it for them it's an issue of
free will democrats think that
everyone's guns should be controlled in
a different way in a harder way in a
tough way or even taken away from them
as an instructor i can tell you right
now because of the increased crime rate
and democrat dominated
uh conclaves
that most of my students
are liberal democrats right now that are
afraid and looking to defend themselves
been several studies that have been done
including the assault weapons ban that
went on in this country for 10 years and
several health studies by the cdc
that have conclusively said that
imposing more restrictions
will not decrease and have not decreased
the illegal use of firearms so why we
are going through this whole drill again
makes no sense
pastor mike would this dynamic be
accelerated perhaps if the equation
between adoption and funding were
shortened and the key way to do that
is on the one hand to get police forces
across the united states to start using
smart guns but on the other hand that's
incredibly difficult because you guys in
the us you have so many you have tens of
thousands of individual police forces up
and down the country and there's 16 000
uh police departments uh in this country
and so any kind of universal adoption of
any policy is quite herculean
again i would just stress that uh we
must continue in this country uh to push
conversations that are about mitigation
uh that are about reducing harm um we
must continue
to shy away from the kind of propaganda
and or uh lighting our hair on fire
about what will not work it is not true
uh that uh the the kinds of
fear-mongering that is happening around
crime uh is actually uh the reality as
it relates to taking guns or owning guns
uh to protect yourself again the
research says if you own a gun you are
more likely uh to have someone in your
family or yourself harmed by that gun
then by using it in a self-defense type
situation we must expand the
consciousness of
everyday citizens in this country around
public safety around personal security
and i believe continuing to adopt and
introduce these kinds of uh
technological advances can contribute to
a conversation where we're not so driven
by fear uh to the point where we
are not embracing
the kinds of mitigation efforts that can
keep us safe thank you so much gentlemen
we've got to leave it there thanks to
our guests they were richard feldman
mike mcbride and chuck nesbi and thank
you too for your company you can see the
show again anytime via the website
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also follow the
conversation on twitter our handle at aj
inside story from me peter dobby and the
team here in doha thanks for watching we
will see you at the usual times tomorrow
bye
[Music]